[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream q a number 98.
we are ready to rock and roll all right
let's do it uh we're gonna we're gonna
crunch it down we're gonna start with
the question from the discord this week
all right shall we
druids
in the irish boho highlands i think i
just stopped there i don't know what
boho refers to haven't been to ireland
much to my chagrin but i love the way
this starts all right i'll start over
druids in the irish boho highlands have
long used soil wrapped in cotton cloth
placed under a pillow to cure ailments
researchers found a new bacterial strain
named streptomyces spa
myrophoria inhibiting four of six mrs
species in it
given the parallel to ivermectin should
we focus more research towards soils
also maybe not drench our fields in
pesticides and herbicides
certainly the latter
yeah um but i mean so it it does raise a
question about what why we might expect
should we expect and if so why might we
expect
soil bacteria to be particularly rich
fodder for useful medicines for humans
or you know so well should should we
expect that that is the case let us let
us tease apart the two things here yeah
one i think it's really cool
that soil bacteria seem to be doing this
but not so surprising when the target is
bacteria themselves bacteria against
bacteria right exactly or were bacteria
against fungi or vice versa right the
natural uh antibiotic tendencies of
these creatures which are battling
everywhere and underground of course
means that they will produce these
chemical warfare agents which by
titrating them we can use against
bacteria that infect us that's not too
surprising that's sort of classic
antibiotic theory
the interesting thing about ivermectin
is that the bacteria that produces it
not only has antibacterial and
antiparasite properties but seemingly
anti-viral properties especially against
uh rna viruses yeah so incredibly broad
spectrum may not be exactly the right
word but
even broader than broad spectrum broad
spectrum typically only to bacteria
right so
i still think what the heck is going on
in japanese soil i bet you there's an
interesting ecological story and it
would be well worth somebody's time to
figure out what it is never mind the
implications for human health there's
going to be some interesting ecological
thing going on there and some
interesting evolutionary history of it
should we expect that maybe this is a
more general property it could be i have
thrown one long shot possibility into
the mix which is that
there might be bacteria phages which
interface in this battle of bacteria
that would explain why viruses are even
in the mix at all
but i'd love to know
that said yeah of course we should be
extremely cautious about these complex
novel biotically active chemicals that
we are drenching everything with in
order to increase yields in an
agricultural context it's insane that's
an easy part of the question right no
matter what else is true that's a bad
idea but it does raise i mean so for
instance when we were doing our graduate
work in central america before i went to
madagascar in um
largely in costa rica and panama
we
uh got a tour of and became familiar
with the workings of inbio uh which is
institut de
instituto de beautiful
i think uh which is basically training
um costa ricans to be what they're
calling parataxonists
um to understand
um to you know widely catalogue right
not necessarily describe the
relationships between which would be the
work of phylogenetic systematists but
catalog the work of taxonomists the
diversity of especially the not so
charismatic not so mega fauna and flora
and other life out in the
in the intact nature in costa rica in
that case
and to what end if memory serves nbo was
partially funded by the costa rican
government but also by merck maybe
i had forgotten this i don't i don't
remember but one one of the major
pharmaceutical companies
and the reason they were interested in
it and um you know they they were doing
they were supporting laudable so-called
basic research right in in biology um
and also this parataxonomist would work
with um systematists and taxonomists
that we knew um who um who were not at
the sort of the parataxonomy level to
actually describe and um
describe the diversity that's out there
but why would pharmaceutical companies
have had an interest in it the idea
being that um of course many of the new
drugs the r d for so many drugs involves
actually going to nature and figuring
out what that is already being produced
might be
useful to be synthesized to be developed
just as
um ivermectin was back in the 70s from
japanese soil what i don't remember
and it's possible we just because of our
interests and because of the kinds of
experiences we had there maybe this work
was going on but what i don't remember
is that nbo had any focus on soil
organisms that it was um largely in fact
insects i think at the time it had none
it may have yeah it may have grown um
and you know part part of it may just be
like we gotta start somewhere
and it's easier to interest for instance
people in cataloging insects than in
cataloging soil
but you know
what
what might we imagine you know if
if you could choose to direct such a
focus at one at just one kind of either
clade or micro habitat within say a
costa rican rain forest with the
potential to not just describe but
potentially increase the likelihood of
drug discovery
what do you think like where where would
that be most likely to be fruitful
fungi
um yeah you know i mean the the typical
thing and i'm i've i have yet to hear a
good explanation for this but plants and
fungi are just simply better at fancy
chemistry than animals
right that the the this the diversity of
chemicals that one can extract from
these things and their
[Music]
biotic interfaces of these chemicals is
staggering is it going to be about sort
of the equivalent of shelf stability you
know animals tend to be mobile plants
and fungi don't tend to be and
motion makes you less shelf stable and
obviously that's the wrong language but
i would guess it's it could be that it's
it has to do with mobile organisms being
[Music]
i would imagine that there's a trade-off
relationship potentially right and that
the idea is a creature that has to be
capable of uh
dynamism of the of the sort that a a
moving creature has may be limited in
other words the burden of these
chemicals may be great enough that the
the elaboration of the machinery to
produce them doesn't
doesn't uh show up the prediction of
that
then might be that um animals that are
sessile or that have a sessile stage
might produce um such you know bioactive
chemical compounds at a higher rate than
you would expect from their
mobile
relatives yeah and actually though maybe
there's another simpler way to do this
maybe the point is um
if you
move you have one less reason to produce
fancy chemicals
right
if the fancy chemicals are defensive
right
well that i think that was an assumption
of what you said yeah yeah i i don't
think it's 100
required but in general yes but there i
mean there are other reasons to produce
fancy chemicals to use our term of art
now um and you know i guess movement
is
among other things an anti-predator
tactic right and so uh so if you have
that you don't need defensive chemicals
as much but that doesn't mean that you
don't have use for
you know other reason to have these
fancy uh right and actually so
um
the
percentage of animals that are toxic is
small the percentage of plants that are
toxic is huge they're almost all toxic
right at least uh at some stage of
development yeah yeah or some part of
them or some stage available i think it
is fair to say almost all plants create
secondary compounds
and you know empirically speaking you
can just
walk into the forest of your choice to
take a leaf and touch it to your tongue
and
find out that you know every alarm bell
goes off and
you're not supposed to be eating that
yeah you gotta be a little careful with
things like uh oleander and things but
but in general you can detect that
you're not supposed to be eating most of
this stuff because it's produced
compounds that would make it very costly
to do so
and you know there are the exceptional
things like the
anticaches
right these are plants that have housed
ants that protect them from herbivores
the ants will sting an herbivore that
climbs the tree they will cut vines and
so they basically have an animal
symbiont and you can take the leaf off
an ant acacia and it does not taste
super bitter right but you better not
stand
touching the antiquation or else the
ants will come out and sting you hurt
yeah yeah so and the ant the plants um
provide homes and nectar not only nectar
but homes like these little like i can't
remember if there's a name for them it's
not domiciles like they have these
hollow thorns the hollow thorns yeah
that's actually live in that has a fancy
name yeah the
i can't remember what the name of the
the homes are and this is not just one
like there are a number of these um
relationships um with a number of
occasions i believe yeah but that one's
super fancy
the
nectaries the fat bodies what are they
called are they called
bayesian bodies or am i borrowing a term
from somewhere else in biology
um anyway i mean yes you are but it
might actually be used here again little
fatty appendages yeah yeah little
nectaries and homes for the ants it's an
amazing relationship and these trees are
incredibly common in central america one
finds them all over the place
but
so i guess what i would say is
if it is true that being able to move
reduces the pressure to generate
secondary compounds maybe increases the
cost belgian belgian belgian bodies
yeah um
then i haven't found the other thing yet
the question is are we overlooking soil
because the organisms are less obvious
obviously we know that there are
bacteria in there right but it's even
less obvious than the hyphae of fungi
and maybe that's a uh a chemical
frontier now this suggests
it's on pinterest um that they're
protein rather than fat rich
um is that right uh
which is possible i'm just not finding
it i believe that i'm probably just
misremembering it yeah yeah now a few of
these looking at protein rich but i'm
not i'm not finding like primary
literature to i know there's a fancy
name for the homes too the hollowed out
thorns
why were we here
uh we were here because the discord
wanted us to address the question about
the soil placed in the bags under the
pillows of people to reduce yes druids
in the um
is it boho some kind of awesome the
irish boho highlands yeah there's also a
lot of uh
soil eating that people do uh typically
the interpretation has to do with
deficiencies but one can also imagine
a
chemical defense against
uh hostile bacteria and things
interesting if you know if of course
you've got you don't have a breach in
your
gut blood barrier
you shouldn't be able to uh get stuff
into your bloodstream by eating it but
um
potentially
um getting you know potentially soil
bacteria that actually had some use in
uh in the gut microbiome no if you had
if you had gut if you had bacteria that
you ingested from soil that were
producing
chemical warfare agents antibiotics
some of them would cross i think many of
them would cross
naturally
from the gut into the blood i mean you
know same as
taking a penicillin pill
yeah yep that's true
all right let's go to questions that
came in
in this last hour or so we're going to
start with um
something from our from from kyle so we
know kyle
and um and we are not going to be doing
this in general because we know kyle we
are going to read this question that
came in from him
um
he says
um hello darkhorse listeners covet has
killed what was left of traditional
dating and online dating simply isn't
suited to those seeking a long-term
relationship so i am trying something
different
if you are or know a single woman who is
looking for a quality partner to raise a
family with then i would like to invite
you to visit www.dataguynamedkyle.com
date a guy named kyle.com i've laid out
the basics of who i am and the kind of
person i'm looking for and i would love
to hear from anyone who thinks they
might be a match for me thanks again you
guys are the best hope you have a great
weekend and i should add didn't make it
into that but
20 off site-wide with the code
dark horse
what do you think um
20 off
what i don't know but i'm assuming
there's a 20 off code no here's here's
what i want to know all right uh
what i want to know so i love the name
of the the url instantly kyle data guy
named kyle
data guy named yeah i mean if you're not
just any guy named kyle this kyle
right yeah we can't vouch for this guy's
name kyle no we can't but we can vouch
for this i know some good guys named
kyle including this one this one this
one seems to be an excellent guy named
kyle and he can code
yeah so date a guy named kyle who can
code that's not the url but yeah maybe
next time it'll be that but yeah i do i
do think you know you and i have been uh
lots of people have
asked us in the aftermath of our book
coming out about uh what we think the
implications of the dating train wreck
are for
future
dating
and i would like to see guys like kyle
who recognize that something's off
specifying some set of new rules for
interacting in this landscape that would
cause people to think actually
right he's not just a guy named kyle he
can co who can code but he's also a guy
who has these values and uh aspires to
these objectives yeah bullet point not
an [ __ ]
that's the first bullet i think a
numbered list in which that was number
one would be great yeah incidentally um
actually this is not not about kyle
sorry to steal any thunder here but um
but i think early this week um the daily
wire is going to be um publish an
excerpt from the book and also a short
essay that uh that we penned on on this
topic right which is totally uh
simpatico with stuff in the book but
sort of on the topic broadly of um in
this day and age how do you find a life
partner yep yeah
all right um i hope it works kyle yeah
it's posted
okay
um
two vaccines the china has
two vaccines that china has shared are
developed by cenopharm labeled coronavac
both are inactivated whole virus
vaccines that is genetic material
destroyed to prevent from
replicating inside the human body tried
and tested technology if china can why
isn't the u.s producing a traditional
vaccine why mrna instead
well
what i would say i wish we were yeah is
i think based on what we have seen
i would certainly be excited to see
a
either inactivated or attenuated yep
viral vaccine which doesn't make those
things perfectly safe but i think the
reason to think
that they might be uh more effective
and uh
that the immunity would be longer
lasting and potentially quite a bit
safer
are quite real i think probably the
reason
well i don't know i mean i'm not
certainly not an expert in this but my
sense was that the rna platform and the
adenovector platform provided a
plug-and-play mechanism that greatly
accelerated
the uh the process of production now i
think the concept that's absolutely
right i think with regard to the mrna it
could be done like in a weekend all
right you can just simply download the
sequence and right and generate it but
the question
is what i think we don't know
is
what this looks like on the inside of
the industry and the point is if
getting out of the gate first gives you
a huge amount of priority with respect
to the regulatory apparatus favoring
your thing because it gives you a
technology you can deploy right away and
that means that anybody who took six
months or a year longer has a
spectacular disadvantage to overcome
because the mrna or the adenovectored
vaccines are already so established
then the point is well this is then a
perverse incentive to use a technology
that may not be the best suited for the
job yeah right and we really you know as
always we have to look at the corruption
of our system because let's imagine that
you know you got to an mrna or
adenovectored
vaccine first
and
it seemed a good bet to use it it seemed
to be very effective and safe enough
based on your testing you might deploy
it but then as indications emerge that
maybe the immunity was very narrow which
of course it would have to be that it
was short-lived which it didn't have to
be but seems to be the case
and then you would compare it to
something else there should be no
priority given to just the earliest
creation right in fact you might even
expect a trade-off
so you know are we getting the best
vaccine technology available pointed at
this or are we getting the fastest and
the one that could therefore make
a splash and you know play a role in the
political realm right well i mean and
the idea that this should be driven by
speed at this point is insane uh early
on having something that had the
potential to be developed so fast
obviously made sense but
um developing that to the exclusion of
uh traditional platforms traditional
techniques never made sense and we are
19 months in now yeah so um
you know we we obviously could be china
is and therefore we could be uh well on
our way to or already deploying
traditional um more traditional or
traditional vaccines as well i can say
and you you know you would you would
certainly reduce vaccine hesitancy by
quite a lot if you did so and if the
goal is to vaccinate everyone um that
would that would contribute to that
there is
one thing that i can see as a possible
argument against
which is in the case of
a
inactivated
virus and that is to say a killed virus
that has been
uh delivered you will be delivering
spike protein
and
that may not in fact it is likely not
worse than the mrna version which is
also delivering spike protein but the
way the mrna version was supposed to
work and actually the adenovector
version also yeah changing the
spike protein was supposed to anchor
in the surface of the cell and therefore
not be floating around but it will
unavoidably be floating around in and
inactivated yeah so an attenuated uh
viral traditional vaccine that excluded
the spike protein
then it wouldn't work uh to no degree
why wouldn't it work to any degree
because well i can't say it wouldn't
work to any degree but i think to work
to a significant degree it has to be
effective at getting into cells and
because the spike protein is key to that
it has to have an effective
spike
i'm not sure about this but uh
let's move on
i'm just going in the order that they
are being fed to me i have not organized
these
sam harris says that he cannot disprove
you in real time but seems fine imposing
his will and knowledge on us via
mandates and censorship if dialectic
isn't an option then it's predetermined
guilt and implied infallibility no
oh boy
um
i have to say
i i think it just needs to be said
there's one thing in what sam has been
saying that i actually agree with
the one thing i agree with is the
frightening prospect of trying to hash
these things out in discussion in real
time
he's not wrong that there's a hazard
that comes from trying to do this via a
debate
now that does not mean there isn't a way
to rig a discussion to avoid that hazard
so that we could actually hash it out
without
opening up the um the discussion to
shenanigans which he fears now he
doesn't need to fear that stuff from us
right we're not going to pull that on
him but i can understand
given where he apparently is mentally on
this topic why
he would be cautious
um
that said yeah
sam appears to be in conflict with
himself and
uh
well
there's a lot more to be said on that
topic but maybe we should leave it there
for now yep
all right uh this next one
i i at least don't have the relevant
information to respond to but i'll read
it
the concept of divine simplicity
is a basis of judaism and most christian
christianity as you spoke of the
multi-four part aspect of evolution i
thought it a perfect argument against
divine simplicity
thoughts
i'm not sure what that's a reference to
right i don't know either the sort of
the four things that they might be
referring to might be the mechanisms of
microevolution yeah there's a lot of
things that come in fours yeah and then
also the four part test of adaptive core
participation the genetic epigenetic
behavioral and symbolic uh modes of
inheritance that uh jablonka and lam
write about in their book
uh so i'm not and no then not being
familiar with the concert to find
simplicity i just think we can't we have
no way we could sort of flail about but
there's lots of fours yep you heard it
here first lots of things come in fours
and three is fives twos
i think quite accidentally for no reason
whatsoever there are several things that
we used in teaching that there were four
of which was a source of confusion
because people sometimes couldn't keep
the list straight
that's interesting i don't i don't
remember this so you're talking about
the four-part test of adaptation
business revolution in terms of that you
know japan
is awesome but i don't think either of
us taught with it so much that that
would have come up a lot yeah um
four characteristics that cause a
pattern to become common yeah yeah yeah
so anyway okay yeah interesting i think
it's just a coincidence frankly yes a
single reason
beyond coincidence for it
um
wilton
will and how might nature respond to our
potential lab leak
and when i guess i don't know what is
meant by nature here you know if we're
talking about sort of wild nature or um
or you know
we are we are all part of nature so well
do you want to take a crack at what
might be meant here there's a lot of
things that could mean we made an
argument early on i i still think it's
important actually it's a
counter-argument to one of the things
that sam has recently said he said he
was quiet about the lab leak because
what difference would it make
and we've we've argued often why would
make a difference right one reason is
because if you've effectively used
uh gain a function if you've used serial
passaging for example to draw a virus in
a direction that it had not already
evolved you've effectively put tension
on a rubber band and you should expect
that when it encounters
the world of phenomena that it will be
pulled in the other direction so you
could predict where it was going to go
now
that said
so for example
were it the case that a serial passage
experiment had resulted in it
surrendering the capacity to transmit
outside because the serial passaging
experiment took place inside
um and it got some characteristic for
foregoing that tension then you would
expect it to return to the ability to
transmit outside right that's one
example of a way in which an experiment
could have pulled it one way and then we
would expect it to naturally fall back
the other way just the same way that if
you i can see the opposite argument
though
i mean in in this case i guess i i had
not before heard you describe this as
like a rubber band the selective force
uh the selective force could also be
accelerating in some directions such
that the the virus now has a tendency to
seek out more change in the same
direction well you could do that too you
could be you could effectively solve a
problem that the virus can't solve in
nature and in fact we did that if this
is election sure
that feels like the more obvious way
that we exerted selective pressure if we
use gain of function to create this
virus yeah but if you think about it
like um
the
[Music]
the argument i made in my dissertation
about the tension between dispersal and
competitive
uh strength
and that effectively
in a maple tree no no in things
generally so if you look at hawaii
that's what i'm saying like
in in anything not specifically viruses
not to humans to anything what you
should what should you expect to be to
to characterize the creatures of hawaii
they're all going to be excellent
dispersers at least the native ones
right what does that mean about their
competitive strength they'll be feeble
because the point is there's a trade-off
between those four reasons i make an
argument for but never mind so the point
is you would expect getting to places
and having gotten there everything else
is just as good at getting places and uh
has not been able to put resources to
competition competitive strength right
yeah so they will they will have
borrowed
to get dispersal they will have borrowed
from competitive strength and they will
have reduced selection for competitive
strength in a low diversity environment
which is a natural consequence of it
being a remote island
that said if you solve a dispersal
problem if you take a mongoose to hawaii
it's going to have a field day because
it's a very strong competitor right and
lots of things so hawaii is very
vulnerable unlike a mainland tropical
habitat hawaii is very vulnerable to
invasion because it has all these feeble
competitors why are they feeble because
they're excellent dispersers if you
overcome the dispersal uh barrier
barrier then
then of course they're going to win
right so
the implication is that we effectively
solved if this was a gain of function
uh escapee we effectively solved a
dispersal problem for the virus so it
didn't have to solve it we gave it the
keys to the human kingdom and then
having gotten in there you would expect
it to find its own equilibrium or you
know potentially the keys to like the
ace ii kingdom right right yeah that
said
we are
okay so we solved the dispersal problem
you would expect it to naturalize into
the human population and then we have
interfered with a novel kind of vaccine
that is almost cartoonishly narrow in
its evolutionary scope and therefore we
are now pushing the virus around we have
used the vaccine to interfere with
now we have interfered with the vaccine
right no we have interfered with the
evolution of the virus after solving a
dispersal problem assuming this was a
lab leak which is an assumption but a
more and more likely one
um
then we are now pushing it around
evolutionarily we're pushing the virus
around evolutionarily so it won't find
an equilibrium it will move in response
to our evolutionary pressure that we are
exerting yep um speaking of which
there's another question here trusting
if sars kovi 2 makes the evolutionary
leap to transmit outdoors you will tell
us
um yes and and what we've said is
although we're not you know especially
in our main podcast we're spending a lot
more time talking about the you know the
broader ideas of the book rather than um
this particular moment in time that we
find ourselves in with regard to covid
stuff um we have said that we you know
if if
things arise uh that run counter to what
we have said publicly we will absolutely
come come back with that and
um
i still have not seen so you have said
that there are a couple of super
spreader events that seem to have been
at outdoor events but it is of course
possible um that the way that they were
effectively super spreader events was in
like bathrooms right uh and so so and
that is the only and i don't actually
even know all i know
my entire knowledge of this is from you
i have seen nothing and it's not for
lack of you know swimming in this
literature a fair bit um to suggest
um that there has been uh anything like
a change in terms of transmissibility
even in the delta variant well um
regard to outdoors versus indoors yeah
so i believe we are beginning to see
that i don't think it's a strong pattern
yet but it's a
what i've seen is not easily dismissed
as it was a bathroom or something like
that that remains a possibility but in
one of these cases it doesn't look
likely but i would also point out it
could be
a natural consequence of the increased
transmissibility
right the idea is if you take the model
that we were developing
a year ago
right where basically you've got a
space it has a volume it saturates at
some rate
um you are not likely to be infected if
you're healthy and you're in the space
for a short period of time um but if
it's saturated you'll get it
and then there's something we need 100
units with the original variant and now
you need 50. right yeah so the point is
it
can you conceive of an outdoor space
that saturates like an indoor space
maybe not with the original variant and
maybe you can with something that's much
more transmissible yep so um you know
something like that that's how my model
is that makes sense no that makes that
that makes some sense yep
uh how do we stop the dangerous and
growing vaccinated versus unboxed false
narrative
oh boy
uh how do we end up here but
look there are ways but it's going to
involve
people not accepting these overly
simplistic perspectives yeah
right and and you know how we do that i
don't i don't know but i mean it really
is like a
if the entire if you're the basis for
your confidence that you're on the right
side here is um a conclusion that you're
not being allowed to show
you're not being allowed to see the
analysis that was used to come to the
conclusion you should be questioning
that
you should you should look for something
that actually has an analysis visible
whether or not you're interested in or
deem yourself capable of interpreting
that analysis i think this is also we
mentioned in the uh initial
podcast today
the danger of verificationism and i
think the problem is if you're a
verificationist and we are all born
verificationists right you have to get
over it
but if you're still a verificationist
and you go looking for evidence of that
simple story you'll find it right if you
go looking for evidence that counter
that contradicts that story you will
find that overwhelmingly as well and so
i think the point is look
the simple stuff
does not fit with the
um
with the
with the actual evidence or the logic
right and so how do we get on the same
page we recognize that you know somebody
uh
engaged in a propaganda campaign
uh under the heading of
pandemic of the unvaccinated right
that's how the demonization began but
that doesn't even make any sense right
logically it doesn't it you know that
doesn't make it a pandemic of the
vaccinated but it means that there is a
role played by the vaccinating which is
required for us to have ended up where
we did
and
you know at the point you see that and
at the point you see
that there are early treatments which
vaccinated people need access access to
because breakthrough cases are real and
common
right so the point is once you see those
two things it isn't a ca a a pandemic of
the unvaccinated and early treatment is
necessary vaccinated or not yeah right
once you see those two things then the
point is we're not two camps
let's get it straight let's figure out
which early treatments work and let's
figure out what to do about our
very
remarkable but not effective vaccines
yeah
uh
related-ish
i just read a recent wapo opinion uh
quote of course hospitals in crisis mode
should consider vaccination status by
tanil r brown
is this how nazi germany started
justifying the dehumanization of other
humans what are your thoughts could you
read the beginning of that question
again i just read a recent wapo opinion
uh the title of which i believe is of
course hospitals in crisis mode should
consider vaccination status
uh okay and then the question sorry now
i've missed the second part is this how
nazi germany started by justifying the
dehumanization of other humans
it is and it isn't i think the problem
is there is a scenario
in which
you would have very good reason to
consider something like vaccination
status and what you would do about it is
not what's being done this is this is a
nonsense story that we're being given
but
um
with frankly with different vaccines and
with a different disease right that's
the point is you don't want to say
anytime anybody says vaccination status
is a relevant medical parameter and uh
of course there are conditions under
which vaccination status
will be a relevant medical parameter but
it's you know i mean let's put it this
way
years ago
um
i proposed a
solution to the problem of
not enough organs for people who need a
transplant
right the idea was if you're an organ
donor you should get priority on organs
if you need one right
you can solve the problem in one fell
swoop right
that's not a matter of dehumanizing
anybody it's a matter of aligning
incentives and one can imagine
a scenario that i do not believe we live
in but one can imagine a scenario in
which civilization has done its part
it's generated excellent vaccines and it
needs a certain level of compliance
which it's not getting for reasons that
don't add up and it does some
prioritization in order to align
incentives so that we get where we're
going we are so far from that story
that's the problem given the particular
tools that we are being told we must use
right yeah
we are being directed to tools we are
being forbidden other tools we are being
demonized for political reasons and all
of those things suggest yeah this is
analogous to um what happens when one
population is preparing to
to decimate another it involves
dehumanization but it doesn't mean that
there's not a medical story that could
contain elements of this absolutely very
good
um
i'm having a hard time parsing this but
you may
you may be able to make sense of it the
problem with the example of
contraception from the amazon review is
the question what if everyone did it in
this case to live child free
the reasonable scientific philosophical
and religious conclusion is no oh i've
got it so i just can't track exactly
what's being said so in the amazon
review which we that two-star review
that we have two star review which we
said uh was obviously critical and we
believe it to be wrong but is a
contribution but it's it's careful
useful it's it is it is intended to be
good critique and it is the basis for a
very important conversation absolutely
okay in the second half of that review
the reviewer talks about the fact that
our model that we put forward uh
effectively where
our
cultural
perspective
is obligated to serve the genes we are
very careful in the book to explain that
as you get towards
modernity you cannot make the assumption
that our cultural
beliefs even expensive ones are serving
the genome because these things haven't
passed the test of time so in order to
know that these things are adaptive they
have to be old enough to see whether or
not those who hold them out can beat
those who don't
the problem
is in fact so i kind of wanted the guy
who wrote that review
i wanted to be in a class where he
submitted that as a paper sure right and
it would be like excellent paper here
are the six ways that you're wrong now
let's go back and forth on it right
the thing that's wrong here is that he's
identified a perfect example of hyper
novelty and the arbitrary distribution
of adaptiveness and changeableness of
various
things so we have made the argument that
it is
selection wants you to produce offspring
that carry your genes to get your genes
into the future
we have a really easy time unhooking our
evolutionary drive to have babies
because birth control allows us to
decouple sex from reproduction we have a
very difficult time controlling the
impulse to have sex and the point is we
are lucky
that
selection did not make the production of
babies pleasurable that it made sex
pleasurable because if it made the
production of babies pleasurable it
would be hopeless
babies would be drowning in babies right
so so the point is this is a great
example
of a hyper novel no simple answer
uh arbitrary mapping of flexibility
because some of it's housed in the
genetic layer and some of it's housed in
the cultural layer it's it's the perfect
example he's just
he's gone one step shy of the actual
conclusion which i mean it also reveals
this uh this idea that i don't think
actually ends up showing up in the book
at all but we've said you know it could
have just about as well been the uh the
title of the book obvious in retrospect
yeah um but
many of the evolutionary ideas that
actually do seem obvious in retrospect
take some time
thinking on them going back and forth
engaging with them and
uh and they won't be obvious in
retrospect uh until zach decides to put
the camera back on the two of us right
because there are two of us here and you
were the one talking yes the one
listening which you know as it turns out
all i had to do was say his name and he
was triggered to uh to put the camera
back on both of us yeah that was cool uh
so anyway
the obvious and retrospect point um
might be seen as too glib and obviously
false because we have also talked about
okay this person appears to be making
for instance i'm not necessarily this
guy but you know a number of people
will be appearing to engage with the
ideas carefully but not be quite getting
it and
some of the obvious and retrospect
points actually take some time you can't
just hear them once or read them once
and and get them they actually take some
going back and forth so you can figure
out
how your model needs to how this model
needs to be applied yeah it's a question
of the
number of things that are wrong with the
model you bring
to your exposure and so you know my
favorite example of obvious in
retrospect is the origin of species
and the point is you know it took
decades and a full book and still you
know it didn't convince people right
away but you know
um
t.h huxley's response i think was
something famously like
why didn't i think of that
right um so you know the point is if you
if you were steeped enough in this kind
of stuff it was
instantly obvious right
um and if you weren't you know it still
may not be obvious to you if you were if
you had enough steps of your model that
were different but
and just uh apropos nothing really t.h
huxley's relationship to al jaz huxley
was like grandfather no i think uncle
cousin cousin cousin 18th removed yeah
something yeah
um please consider inviting dr paul
saladino on the podcast would be
fascinating to hear you discuss diet and
evolution with him are you familiar with
him
i am not although the last time i said i
wasn't familiar with somebody it turned
out i was very much familiar with him
yes indeed yes um neil oliver neil
oliver indeed yes um yeah we are it
turns out both just had forgotten the
name yeah terrific um but so maybe that
will prove to be true here
i apologize if so
um
psa for those looking for talented
anti-woke musical artists tom mcdonald
is the goat might be an interesting
podcast guest
clown world
must be his first album
um
i'm 30 and a fit retired medic
on verge of saying [ __ ] it and old
school inoculating myself in isolation
before a more lethal variant emerges
please steal me on the case for why i'm
[ __ ]
this is from someone called the right to
bear markets
um alternately the right to bear markets
so
the person
is talking about
contracting covid to generate
immunity that's what they're arguing for
yeah and it took me a couple of reads
to figure out that's what they're
talking about
yep um steelman the case for why
you're [ __ ] um
oh here's why you're you know i can i
can easily steal man the case for you
being [ __ ] you're [ __ ] be caught
yes wow
he asked for it no
that's not a term i use and it's not a
term
i'm going to use here
um here's the error that you're making
you are making
an error because we do we cannot rule
out certain downstream consequences of
covid disease itself
among them are the possibility that it
hides in some tissue in which your
immune system cannot clear it and
therefore people who have had it still
have it and we don't know that that is a
possibility i don't think it's likely
but it's possible
it is also possible that the consequence
of having covid the destruction that it
does to the body will have some
implication down the road that we cannot
see and so although you are right
that future variants
are a frightening prospect because we
don't know what their nature will be and
therefore you're comparing
current coveted horror to unknown
magnitude future coveted horror
it is not
a simple matter of well let's deal with
this and be done with it because you
don't really know that you can be done
with it you don't know that you can be
done with it
so far the variants seem to be more
transmissible not more deadly
but of course that is not a pattern that
is under any obligation to stay the same
yeah yeah so anyway that's the steel man
it doesn't necessarily
it is what it is it is what you asked
for except for that term which i should
not have allowed myself to fall into
um did higher calorie intake help us
evolve advanced brands could modern
calorie dense diets allow us to become
even more intelligent
one of the um leading hypotheses one of
the hypotheses that we take seriously in
the book
about
some of the
move towards higher cognitive capacity
in humans is about fire
and then the cooking of food the cooking
of food which allows us to get more
nutrient load out of every bit of food
that we eat and thus allow it gives us
more time also so cooking up food gets
us to more nutrient load more nutrients
out of our food and also spend less time
actually actually eating it and i think
if so this is
um
richard rangham
important amazing primatologist who has
written many papers on this but also the
book called
catching fire something no i can't
remember it's anyway um
i'll look it up after when you're
talking because it's in here as well um
argues that uh i think some of his
research has shown that uh eating an
entirely raw diet
that is somewhat heavy in meat a person
would be chewing for like five hours a
day i think i think that's the number
that he comes up with him and his the
researchers he's working with on that
paper um which would have obviously
gotten in the way of things like talking
and sharing ideas and engaging with one
another in anything besides mastication
so
to the degree that
we were able to get more out of our food
that may well have been part of what
increased kind of capacity but the idea
that it's simply that we need more food
and that that increases brain size there
are limits on brain size um that have to
do with um
when in your development you're born and
to what degree you can continue to alter
women's hips compared to men's hips and
still have us be you know basically
similar enough that we can
engage with one others the same species
that we're already sort of at the limit
of
width of female hips with regard to
stability uh issues so um there are
there are things restricting the upper
bound of brain size at least where we're
born and we're already born so helpless
that being born even more helpless and
thus with a smaller brain earlier in
development would put us at even greater
risk
all right so
cooking food
liberates more nutrition
uh it reduces the amount of time
necessary to process it and it makes
food more tastier which is good a little
tastier um
what i would add to your actually
catching fire catching fire that's human
yep rang them 2009 yep all right so what
i would add and i agree with your
analysis as far as it went the limits
may not be about um
in fact we have too much food we know
that right totally so it food is not the
limiting factor we're not getting
smarter
no we're not uh we're not getting smart
do not appear to be getting smarter
right here's the other thing though in
order to get this you know if it was
true that our
cognitive capacity was food limited and
then we had more food
and for some reason the limits that you
heather point to were not
driving it would have to be the case
that the extra cognitive capacity
resulted in more offspring which is a
very unlikely connection in modern times
right
yeah um no i mean it just it simply is
right if you if you just imagine for a
moment a world in which we are limited
by calories in terms of our cognitive
capacity and then suddenly you remove
the limit of calories that does not
result
you know in people
uh outwitting each other to reproductive
ends
right it results in people hanging out
in
salons and talking about
interesting patterns but i don't know
that that results in babies
not usually no no
all right um
i don't i'm not familiar enough with
this to respond but i'll read the
question the uk vaccine surveillance
reports
show that for many ages that is many
ages of people vaccinated have higher
per capita infections than unvaccinated
what are your thoughts
i wish the data was better but yes one
hears
a lot about anomalous patterns that i
have the sense we are not following up
on and
may or may not
imply
things that we should know yeah i agree
could taking neurogenic compounds like
lion's mane increase the risk of
neuronal cancer
um neuronal cancer is very rare in
general for this reason brain tumors are
the result of
auxiliary cells associated they are
present in the brain but they're not
neurons themselves and the reason for
this is almost certainly is it glial
cells or is it yeah i think it's i think
there are several different kinds um but
yeah supportive cells are are the uh
the ones that create tumors
the reason for this is probably
that
the neurons do not do their neuronal
magic by making more neurons in general
they make their magic by making more
dendritic connections and so
the point is to the extent that a tumor
is a cell producing too many daughter
cells
or dividing too frequently
it is not the division of neurons that
is the way the brain works
so
it it does happen but it's rare it's
more about synaptic connectivity it's
not zero but it's not a real productive
tissue it's not a growth industry
as an adult
right
right it's not yeah yeah
um
although you could get an analog of
cancer
in which you got the proliferation of
dendrites beyond what would be useful
and i'm going to propose the name for
the melody would be
galaxy brain
brought on perhaps by lion's mane too
much
yeah i had completely forgotten the
lion's mane
uh connection but yes you could get a
case of galaxy brain from lion's mane so
yeah
yeah we should put that disclaimer at
the beginning of those ads we need to
know the latin for
galaxy uh
fungivore
emptor
no
caveat
[Laughter]
something like that yes
okay uh i i have some glimmer of
recognition about this but i can't quite
remember i'll bet you will and you will
still deflect that's my prediction
brett as heather has asked what is the
joke the one your dad told
so you do
you do remember oh i know the joke okay
yeah um
wow
i wish i could i'm just reading
questions
i'm concerned if i tell this joke even
as a historical artifact that people
might throw a rope on me and try to tear
me down like some kind of statue to a
past era right i just
sort of elk-like in you yeah exactly
exactly seriousness um impact
yeah we really need to get back to a
world where i can tell that joke because
it's really is an evolutionarily very uh
insightful joke if offensive how about
this can we um offer
landing psyche if that is in fact how
you pronounce your your name here um
that off air since i as i predicted he's
not gonna do it um that you will tell me
and our sons this joke i'm sure i've
heard it before but i don't know what
you're talking about yet uh and that we
will work with you to figure out if
there is a way to do this without being
um treated like a common elk statue
you're gonna help me figure my i just
think that this is not no promises i'm
not saying it's possible but but you
will they have been relentless in trying
to cancel the the the big things
well they have changed identities and
all sorts of people who were not
initially in favor of the cancellation
at all have now switched teams and are
now trying to cancel you may have
noticed that i have in fact noticed yes
you've noticed so you know i just wonder
if this joke is the thing that's going
to get me canceled and it's going to
cause
near universal agreement in the fact
that i am not so you want to have this
polite society have some stickiness on
that new york times bestseller list
before maybe going into this territory i
would like a stunt double to tell this
joke so that he can be canceled if not
killed and i can go on living a life
that i'm quite enjoying you're not
advocating for the killing of your stunt
double
no no no no no um i mean i guess it's
cheaper
unless he's paid in advance but
so this is okay but this joke isn't
really
how could this joke be
that's a great joke actually but
you're not helping yourself no i'm not
yeah i just i don't
i'm i'm enjoying life too much to to
exit on this journey i'm glad to hear it
yes yes so at the point that you get to
the uh the dying and time stage as roger
scrutin uh wrote before he himself died
what seemed to all of us an untimely
death
um
maybe then you will
you will share
the joke deathbed confession joke
yeah
sure no that makes good sense before if
if were the world to write itself and
allow for you know jokes at the edge of
tolerableness sure
okay
55 minutes all right um
please acknowledge stanislav petrov day
tomorrow lieutenant colonel in the
soviet air defense credited with
preventing nuclear war on september 26th
1983. yeah you recognize his name i did
not recognize his name but i recognized
the date yep
the dude refused to launch the nukes
um which frankly is the duty of every i
think it is actually a natural extension
of the nuremberg trials
right yep yeah i think this is the one
holiday
yeah you don't follow immoral orders um
yes we are learning actually that
stanislav
there is a
arms race afoot
and those who wish to give immoral
orders are
creating conditions in which those who
will resist moral orders cannot immoral
or
resisting moral orders that's not a
thing well it is but it shouldn't be no
those who are likely to resist immoral
orders are being driven crazy and
therefore leaving their posts
which is going to leave
a
population of order followers who
don't get it
from
law enforcement to
medical care providers yes i think it is
a general next phase in the arms race
but yes i have heard it from law
enforcement and
it is
absolutely frightening especially in
light of what is taking place in
australia
yep
yep so stanislav petrov day tomorrow
excellent
excuse me
i like your idea fourth frontier
others think that next frontier is body
mind tech merge
iob
what's iob stand for zach
um
okay uh and then there's a link to
something
internet of
brains
uh there's a there's a url silicon
icarus.org transhumanism
thoughts
um
yeah you know we've been we've been
hearing more and more of this i think
you know i think joe rogan brought it up
yep i think uh
brian king brought it up um
a number of people feel like this is
where we're going they don't want us to
be going there but it's inevitable well
okay first off we got to relax
do we yeah really a little this doesn't
sound like you
we got to relax get our head in the game
and then leave nothing on the table
leave it all in the field i don't know
no we don't need to relax but we need to
relax about the idea of the tech merge
because it's too late it's already
happened
okay okay okay okay yeah yeah the thing
is you you you have already merged but
because the interface isn't
wires
for example it is somewhat invisible to
us
now that said
but i mean i i mean i found myself doing
this today just like the you know out in
nature like i'm just going to look at
this right oh yeah they got you terrible
yeah completely awful absolutely crazy
um but anyway i think the point is look
it's happened
we can see that the consequences are not
entirely horrible but yeah
a lot of them are
really catastrophic and it's disrupting
and some of them will be irreversible
right so well you know
hence what we do argue in the book which
is that you you
put your phone down
really put it down well put your phone
down but you know look if you're going
to make a transition about which you
know very little about the consequences
then you better be prepared to unmake
that transition and the way we adopted
the smartphone yeah
you know what seems like forever ago but
wasn't
i mean it really wasn't it really wasn't
it really wasn't yeah um
the point is oh you completely changed
how the species works
and not all to the good in fact it may
be that the species is incapable now of
navigating because we are so easily
divided from each other over things that
should absolutely be galvanizing us
right so if that's true if a technology
can sweep to fixation
it's not quite fixation glenn beck does
not have a phone but everybody else does
well um now everybody else almost
everybody else with the means
which means you know some people in the
non-weird world
um to have it but many people don't and
um and some number of people in the
weird world just don't have the means
for either well i'm being glib of course
but my sense is that
the
[Music]
yes there are people who don't have
a
smartphone in the us
very few right it's my impression right
i even i'm not saying it's universal in
the homeless population but it's exactly
somehow i don't know how i mean maybe
their burner phones are i mean they're
uh prepaid or whatever but
um is that a thing in smartphone land i
don't i don't know but yes i you and i
have yes it is okay so zach says yes
burner
prepaid smartphones but yes even even
among the homeless um
who have almost nothing there are people
with with smartphones right so anyway uh
and you know also as you and i have
encountered
lots of people haven't in fact there are
lots of places in the world where the
landline network never got up and
running and so right but you know and
then so this is a little different
though we haven't been back for instance
to madagascar since the late 90s yep in
the by the mid 90s in madagascar we you
know we didn't have cell phones until
2003 for something like that cell phones
even we didn't we personally didn't
almost every all of our colleagues did
but we were like nah not sure um
basically at the point that i was late
stage pregnancy with zach it's like okay
we gotta get phones um but mid late 90s
when a lot
increasingly people were getting cell
phones but by no means was it universal
in the usa in madagascar uh many people
had cell phones but
smartphones didn't exist and you know
they're they were cheap flip phones and
we i have no idea not having been back
to madagascar since 99.
um
what the distribution of
uh flip phones versus smartphones looks
like what we were seeing was
because it is such an impoverished
country with so little ability to put in
infrastructure landlines just never went
in so there you know there are there are
a couple places you know i imagine tana
has some landlines and such and you know
some of the bigger cities but um
throughout most of the country there
just are no there's no capacity well the
cell phone was just superior because you
could actually
call from places and reach people and
other things that you might want to do
oh my god
trying to make a landline call just to
our parents at some point like 93 or
something and
i don't know it took three hours and we
still were able to be like we're alive
bye
all right we still don't know whether
they thought that was a good or a bad
thing the parents on the other end the
parents they probably thought it was a
good thing that we were alive yeah
probably
um yeah i don't remember the nature of
the question but oh i know that yeah the
uh the borg and whether or not
transhumanism yeah yeah yeah yeah i
resist i hope did you figure out what
iob means
[Music]
it's on what it's on pitch no it's going
to be
internet of
something
i don't think that's great i think it
would have been a little o then it would
have been a little lower
um
okay
it's on [ __ ] it's on [ __ ] yeah all
right um
so
we do these things
it's increasingly catastrophic we need
to stop doing these things and not doing
these things means reversibility
yeah reversibility exactly yeah all
right um
chris martinson interviewed david ick or
icky i don't know how his name is
pronounced
time to digest that covered response is
beyond incompetence and greed money
greed psychopathy at the top explains a
lot
i have not seen that interview i'd be
interested chris martinson is fabulous
um
yep
i don't know anything about it
okay um
are you actually going to make an
epigenetically how dare you shirt please
do
i like it it's just it's
i mean i guess it's just such an inside
joke that people would have to be
willing to wear an inside joke because
for the most part people be like what
it's a conversation starter it is that's
that's one of the ways to um to find
your life partner to find your life
partner it's somebody who's interested
what that could possibly mean and it
also could be a fire starter if
it was cold or something
oh it's like the towel and hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy so many reasons to
carry an epigenetically to wear an
epigenetically how dare you shirt you
can soak it in liquid nutrients and then
suck on it when you're hungry
right or if it's cold you could start a
fire with it which might attract
somebody who knows how to solve the
problem so what can solve any problem
potentially the problem now being how to
put out a fire made by your shirt what
whatever problem you have
we're not even high guys we're not
um
are
our house pets suffering the effects of
modernity in a manner similar to us
um to some degree yeah diet oh my god
we're completely messing up them we're
completely messing up our animals with
the with the food we give them um
restricting them to activity at only
certain prescribed moments of the day
um yeah well i would i would point to
one thing in particular okay
the degree to which
pets are now suffering sensitivities to
food
i did say diet i know but diet the
obvious one is hey everybody's pets are
fat right
yep that's bad but the degree to which
pets are reacting presumably
allergically to their food is alerting
us to something the same way humans are
becoming allergic to their food
something is doing that and to the
extent that we can't say exactly what it
is that is alarming yeah there was no
i'm going to go out on a limb here and
say in the 1930s
no vets were saying you need to put your
cat or dog on an elimination diet right
elimination diets now for for humans and
our domesticates
are not just all the rage but they
actually are necessary in many of our
cases to figure out what it is that
we've what it is that is now poisoning
us even though it's not a poison
universally across the species do you
hear the one about the chameleon who had
to start eating fireflies
no they put them on an illumination diet
oh
okay
i feel good about it actually yeah
you do
[Laughter]
my my objection is only chameleon it
didn't have to be a chameleon yeah it
did why oh so much more vivid
what else would it have been
so for me maybe most people don't do
this but for me when you say chameleon i
imagine like a
first for pardellus or something and
like it's one that has a really strong
ability to change colors
and so at the point that it's eaten the
fireflies i don't actually get the
illumination i'm just sort of seeing
like it's slightly brighter red and
maybe that's just me yeah i think that's
okay i think that's just you the
importance of the joke was that it
vividly evoked a chameleon shooting its
tongue out and grabbing a firefly which
is already kind of cool right most jokes
don't have that yeah i didn't i think i
think it needs another half sentence of
setup
to
to get the uh
the capture
all right
i don't know what the half sentence
would be but i don't either yeah either
why when out walking do i feel compelled
to walk in step with the rhythm of music
well
i
there are a couple answers to that
question these are all half baked but i
have a feeling there's something
something useful in here
one there is some kind of a time keeping
something or other in our
neurological structure
certain drugs bring it out
you can reveal it
but
say more about that
i can say is uh empirically speaking
certain drugs bring out a
some sort of
kind of a metronome oh okay okay you're
not right okay
um likewise there are lots of processes
in the body that seem to be synchronized
temporally and it would not be
surprising if a feat as remarkable as
walking involved some of these processes
and that these processes were also
involved in
music
you know in other words like yeah
think about it this way but i mean also
music is synchronizing it's
synchronizing of brains and it may be
synchronizing of bodies as well we
certainly we can all come up with
examples of ways of moments in which
music has been intentionally
synchronized right
you know among marching armies or among
gandy dancers right
uh where you want to be in sync and you
use music or you know among um rowers
right
so
it doesn't feel like synchronicity when
there's only one of you but it could be
appealing to that same circuit
i agree
um
but i was
sorry
no no no i mean
somewhere in this neighborhood is gonna
be something but
i just wanna i robbed you of it thought
you did i'm sorry there was some thing
and it was it was it was kind of cool
i'm trying to think what the hell was it
now i owe
yes exactly
yeah
do you know what it was zach that your
dad was going to say
yeah i'll get back there
all right okay we're going to go move on
i'll get back excellent excellent so uh
we'll we'll stop here soon um
what's the status of heather's novel
thoughts on traditional publishing
versus self
publication
um
you know we've been our
our editor was asking us what we're
going to do next um what
what books we want to write next and
i do want to get back to
the
science fiction novel of which i have a
completed second draft but i literally
have not looked at since probably early
2018 at this point um
and i just haven't at this point i don't
think i don't think it'll be the next
one although there are certainly people
we've talked to tell bill you um jordan
hall our friend
who definitely want that to be top of
the list so um
so yeah i do i do want to get back to it
um traditional publishing versus
self-publishing uh yeah we
i published a book
20 19 years ago i didn't publish it i
also i had a big publisher
um who published my first book but i was
not known in any way at that point i was
lucky enough to get this big publisher
because
you knew me um but i won this writing
prize in the atlantic monthly which
allowed me to get this this big
publisher but i was unknown and i was
writing a book that was going to have
somewhat limited appeal and so
um
it i there was there was no push like i
felt well treated by my editor for sure
but there was
and self-publishing wasn't wasn't a
respected thing at that point so it
wasn't even an option but
um it wasn't clear to me sort of what
the publisher was doing for me so much
obviously traditional publishing has
some some risks to it at this point with
regard to not being treated well inside
the publication engine um you know being
cancelled therein um our publisher
penguin portfolio has been true utterly
terrific with us like re really been
remarkable in every regard so um you
know we only have really those two
experiences with traditional publishers
and i would say in the first case st
martin's um i was treated well i just
there was just sort of no not a lot of
help and um
here we've been treated so well that um
at the moment i feel like don't mess
with the thing that's working
yeah yeah
all right i figured out what i forgot
excellent does this mean i don't owe or
do i still owe oh you're still oh okay
definitely just want to make sure yeah
it's good to be clear about it yeah um
all right
here's the argument this is again about
uh walking and rhythm and all of that
neurons transmit information kind of
like wires but they're not like wires in
that the information because it
transmits as a result of channels on the
surface of the neuron opening and ions
flowing in transmit information way
slower than wires right
so that means that distances that exist
in a body are actually meaningful in
terms of how long these things take
which makes the process of learning how
to do something like walk
much harder because if what you need is
to send an impulse that causes a muscle
in your foot to contract and then you
need the feedback that says yep did it
right then the point is that's a long
process even in a myelinated neuron
system you're gonna have that's too long
so what you need to do
is send a message and even if it's cns
from the base of the spine like it
doesn't necessarily need to be going all
the way up to
brain but it might be it has to be
central nervous system which means it at
least has to get up to your pelvis
region right yeah let's put it this way
it's too long a distance to do it as a
you know a signal goes and a sensory
feedback returns
so what what do you do well you have to
send a message that you know how it will
interact with the muscle and then you
need to track how long it will take
before the muscle contracts right and so
the idea of having a kind of clock-like
thing working in the background that
says you know yeah that message should
have just arrived right you don't need
the feedback to know that it did that
would be an important way of building
such a system and the bigger the
creature it is the more likely the more
elaborate that system would have to be
in order to coordinate what the brain of
the creature wants done with the body of
the creature and it's being done
so like a giraffe for example can run
right but the distances in a giraffe are
huge yeah right and so anyway imagine
that it has some kind of rhythm thing in
it so they can track
these things i can imagine there might
be if this is if this is an accurate
model
uh something in here about um
enhancing the learning of walking in
babies and toddlers with um
appropriately timed syncopated music
playing as they are engaged in
trying to walk well i guess what i'm
arguing is that you would imagine
if you think about let's say that you
have a sequence of
flexes of the leg that need to happen in
order to walk right but the second one
in the sequence has to happen before a
feedback from the first one could
possibly have returned
right so you have to send them at the
right distance apart in time in order to
get the leg to do the thing
and you say oh i consciously moved my
leg and the point is well you
consciously sent a bunch of signals
knowing that they would arrive at the
right distance apart in order to get the
leg to do the thing that it did right
so
um that kind of system
would then interface obviously with the
learning you would have to learn like
how to load in the motions that you sent
the information about at the right
distance apart and then eventually you'd
get so good at it that you would just it
would take no thought you would just be
like yeah run you know like the way we
do right yeah yeah um yep and the last
thing was gonna be
um oh yeah so if you had that system
of some sort of
clock like time keeper in the
central nervous system that kept these
things the right distance apart and then
you pick up music because music becomes
somehow useful for humans
it doesn't matter why in this case and
the point is you would expect it to tap
into that thing because in many ways
it's the same phenomenon right like if
you're
plucking guitar strings you know you may
need to send the message to this for the
second pluck before the first one has
reached your ear
right
that kind of thing
good
good
but yeah you still up yeah i know
uh two last questions one of which is
just a comment
please start accepting bitcoin paypal
will start cracking down eventually
so here's the question
yeah we would totally be up for
accepting the bitcoin but how do we get
that to interface with the system
yeah i don't know
but we should think about it i think we
should we would be
thrilled we'd love to and of course um
odyssey accepts um
lbry lbry yeah which i think they
pronounced library but yeah lbry
um so some kind of interface there where
you know also accepting questions there
may be
something
um
so here's the problem
lbry must be purchasable somehow but i
don't think it's
lbc library
oh library currency okay
so that's right i was looking at
coinbase recently
it's possible that i need to go back and
look at lbc but i think the thing is
with coinbase which is one of the
simplest ways to do crypto
you're limited to the currencies that
are
uh frequently traded right you can trade
between them in fact but the point is it
you can't just trade any crypto with it
yeah um so i don't know we have to
figure this out but yeah i think it's a
great idea yep
final question for today
could embracing despair help at this
time rather than hope hope seems
impotent
i don't think so
i don't think
i think grief is often adaptive
sadness
uh moroseness
but despair as the opposite of hope as
as a as a kind of hopelessness
uh effectively guarantees
that you won't escape from whatever it
is and uh you know actually we argue in
the book we give a little um
a little story about you're in a boat um
on a river and you find that you're
being pulled
more and more quickly and that you're
near the top of a waterfall you didn't
know existed
and you start paddling like hell even
though as you get pulled faster and
faster towards that top of that
waterfall over which you will likely
plunge and you have no idea how high it
is and it seems ever more likely that
you're going to die
despairing guarantees your death
maintaining hope even as the evidence
looks more and more like your
hopefulness is somewhat delusional is
the only possible chance you have yeah
there's no situation there's no
evolutionary
reward
for giving up um
i mean there are circumstances in which
there could be but the point is in the
case where you don't know that it's
hopeless giving up hope can't possibly
solve the problem and
uh therefore even tiny amounts of hope
are enough but at this point i would in
or in this in reference to this question
i would say
a
i think it's just i think it's set up
wrong
right i do think that there's something
to be said for
looking into the abyss abyss but in
order to get over it
right you have to look at it and you've
got to say yep
that sucks and it's going to take you a
little time are you looking that sucks i
shouldn't have gotten here we shouldn't
have allowed it to happen
but we are here and then at the point
that you've just sort of grown
accustomed to it then the point is then
you can go back to doing stuff that's
useful
and
that's what you need and so i think
people spend so much time avoiding
looking into the abyss lying to
themselves about it that they actually
end up paralyzed in this sort of
you know
pre-despair state
rather than just i mean if you think
about it this way all right so suppose
it could be it could be regarded that
you're actually advocating for a stare
into the abyss embrace the despair but
make sure that that's finite
absolutely absolutely so but that but
that is a little bit of a different
answer than what i gave
yeah no i i yeah i i really think it's
it's something you don't know unless
you've
been put through something that causes
you
to do it or to have no choice but to do
it but but the point is something like
things are very serious
that could preoccupy you to no useful
effect
if hope is effectively lost
then you have license to gamble on
things that might work
right and so the point is there's a
liberation
you know
i'm not going to quote the song lyric
but there is a liberation that comes
from the recognition that probably
there's nothing that's going to
successfully address the issue
and frankly i think people would be
mentally healthier if they
found themselves there and and
ironically would be a lot more likely to
solve the problem because if your point
is yep
i've seen it i've seen the monster it
seems very dangerous
uh let's figure out what our best shot
is and let's take our best shot because
what else are we gonna do right it's
sort of the let's roll
kind of thing right
um
and i yes i absolutely advocate and i
think it's healthy and frankly i think
if you do it
you will end up finding that there are
others and you will join them and you
will feel a lot better about life right
at least you know if it's not going to
work it's not going to work and you'll
at least know who to talk to about it
and not feel crazy and if it is going to
work it's going to be the people who
aren't paralyzed by
despair who um are gonna figure out what
to do so
it's sort of the right answer no matter
what
very good
so
that brings us to the end yes not the no
just the end of the podcast it felt like
that brought us to the end
no did i take the wrong message from no
i think you're still looking into the
abyss yeah it's uh
it's gonna be okay you heard it here
first
it's gonna be okay
perfect
sure it will and it cosmic sense
we will be back next week with episode
99 of dark horse live stream the week
after that what would be episode 100 is
actually going to be a break week for us
because uh two of our family are going
to be traveling then
so episode 100 will be one week later
than we are expecting but we will be
back next week with episode 99 until
then
be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside
be well everyone it's just an abyss
[Music]
[Music]
you